are there particular books
that you enjoyed that had an impact on
you for silly or for profound reasons
that you recommend
you mentioned the vital question
many of course I think in biology as an
example the vital question is a good one
anything by McLean really uh life
ascending I would say is like a bit more
potentially representative as like a
summary
of a lot of the things he's been talking
about I was very impacted by the selfish
Gene I thought that was a really good
book that helped me understand altruism
as an example and where it comes from
and just realizing that you know this
election is in the level of genes was a
huge insight for me at the time and it
sort of like cleared up a lot of things
for me what do you think about
the the idea that ideas of the organisms
the means yes love it 100
[Laughter]
are you able to walk around with that
notion for a while that that there's an
evolutionary kind of process with ideas
as well there absolutely is there's
memes just like genes and they compete
and they live in our brains it's
beautiful are we silly humans thinking
that we're the organisms is it possible
that the primary
organisms are the ideas
yeah I would say like the the ideas kind
of live in the software of like our
civilization in the in the minds and so
on we think as humans that the hardware
is the fundamental thing I human is a
hardware entity yeah but it could be the
software right yeah
yeah I would say like there needs to be
some grounding at some point to like a
physical reality yeah but if we clone an
Andre
the software is the thing
like is this thing that makes that thing
special right yeah I guess I you're
right but then cloning might be
exceptionally difficult like there might
be a deep integration between the
software and the hardware in which we
don't quietly understand well from the
other thing point of view like what
makes me special is more like the the
gang of genes that are writing in my
chromosomes I suppose right like they're
the the replicating unit I suppose and
no but that's just a few the thing that
makes you special sure wow
the reality is what makes you special is
your ability to survive
based on the software that runs on the
hardware that was built by the genes
um so the software is the thing that
makes you survive not the hardware
all right you know it's just like a
second layer it's a new second layer
that hasn't been there before the brain
they both they both coexist but there's
also layers of the software I mean it's
it's not it's a it's a abstraction
that's uh on top of abstractions but
okay so selfish Gene um McLean I would
say sometimes books are like not
sufficient I like to reach for textbooks
sometimes
um I kind of feel like books are for too
much of a general consumption sometime
and they just kind of like uh they're
too high up in the level of abstraction
and it's not good enough yeah so I like
textbooks I like the cell I think the
cell was pretty cool
uh that's why also I like the writing of
uh McLean is because he's pretty willing
to step one level down and he doesn't uh
yeah he's sort of he's willing to go
there
uh but he's also willing to sort of be
throughout the stack so he'll go down to
a lot of detail but then he will come
back up and I think he has a yeah
basically I really appreciate that
that's why I love college early college
even high school but just textbooks on
the basics yeah of Computer Science and
Mathematics of of biology of chemistry
yes those are they condense down like a
uh it's sufficiently General that you
can understand the both the philosophy
and the details but also like you get
homework problems and you you get to
play with it as much as you would if you
were in yeah programming stuff yeah and
then I'm also suspicious of textbooks
honestly because as an example in deep
learning uh there's no like amazing
textbooks and I feel this changing very
quickly I imagine the same is true and
say uh synthetic biology and so on these
books like this cell are kind of
outdated they're still high level like
what is the actual real source of truth
it's people in wet Labs working with
cells yeah you know sequencing genomes
and
yeah actually working with working with
it and uh I don't have that much
exposure to that or what that looks like
so I sold them fully I'm reading through
the cell and it's kind of interesting
and I'm learning but it's still not
sufficient I would say in terms of
understanding well it's a clean
summarization of the mainstream
narrative
yeah but you have to learn that before
you break out yeah towards The Cutting
Edge yeah or what is the actual process
of working with these cells and growing
them and incubating them and you know
it's kind of like a massive cooking
recipe so making sure your self-slows
and proliferate and then you're
sequencing them running experiments and
uh just how that works I think is kind
of like the source of truth of at the
end of the day what's really useful in
terms of creating therapies and so on
yeah I wonder in the future AI textbooks
will be because you know there's a
artificial intelligence the modern
approach actually I haven't read if it's
come out the recent version the recent
there's been a recent Edition I also saw
there's a science a deep learning book
I'm waiting for textbooks that worth
recommending worth reading It's tricky
because it's like papers
and code code honestly papers are quite
good I especially like the appendix
appendix of any paper as well it's like
it's like the most detail it can have
it doesn't have to be cohesive to
connected to anything else you just
describe me a very specific way you
solved a particular thing yeah many
times papers can be actually quite
readable not always but sometimes the
introduction in the abstract is readable
even for someone outside of the field uh
not this is not always true and
sometimes I think unfortunately
scientists use complex terms even when
it's not necessary I think that's
harmful I think there's no reason for
that and papers sometimes they're longer
than they need to be in this in the
parts that
don't matter yeah appendix would be long
but then the paper itself you know look
at Einstein make it simple
yeah but certainly I've come across
papers I would say in say like synthetic
biology or something that I thought were
quite readable for the abstract and the
introduction and then you're reading the
rest of it and you don't fully
understand but you kind of are getting a
gist and I think it's cool